yes you just told Brad right to shut
up I me what the [__] were you
thinking hell I had to I had to we'll
never be invited back we'll never be
invited back um yeah Sarah When Brad R
said yeah
to so I me and Brad have got a similar
blad problem um oh just just amazing um
so guys did you enjoy
that
unbelievable I told you to shut up that
was freaking
great oh just think Amazon panel is live
and there is a stream and I was
listening to it and listening to think
and it so far Marco if you're listening
to it brilliant but so far it is what we
said it was going to be really it's a
bunch of Amazon TV shows they're talking
about they've got the guys from the boys
on and um and a couple of other things
when I was listening
[Music]
um uh what was embarrassing I don't I
don't know what was embarrassing the
question what um but oh w i i i so when
I when I asked him to tell you to [__]
up and then I so hoping that's what he
was going to
do that's
awesome what stood out for you
mate oh God I don't know I don't know
[Music]
um I mean
I I I I loved so not focus on on our
stuff but all of the all of the
questions that were were were asked I
thought were really good and it was
really insightful really like we
actually it wasn't just another um
another random interview where he's
gonna answer the same questions again
there was some genuinely good questions
on that so I feel like we got to to to
find out a little bit more um I was
especially intrigued because we we
obviously knew that it was going to be a
human built Stargate in his mind yeah
but that what he described I genuinely
want to see that and it's sad that we
probably
won't yeah I
um yeah Kevin mccab there like when see
us I I think it's fair to say when we
first appeared we didn't have the best
relationship with gate world and D the
gate they are very much just
Brad the team Brad so when we started
coming out particularly and started
saying Brad W's not going to be involved
in this they didn't like that message it
wasn't it wasn't us we didn't want we
didn't like it but you know that was
just what it was and you know um but
we've built those bridges water under
bridge bygones and all that and now they
at the end of the day they're two lovely
guys that love love Stargate as much as
we do so why wouldn't we you know hit
that like button please guys come on
because and another live just we want to
show that love across three five short
particularly you know they need our love
they go subscribe to our Channel because
they talk star get and they're amazing
but um oh man yeah the him talking about
the gate that they
planned having like see through bits and
stuff as well
and um that thing about you know the sg1
SGA and SGU movie I thought that was a
myth did you know about that I I'd heard
that story but I didn't think it was
true I didn't I don't think I've ever
heard it
no I just I love that idea of I mean God
man if we'd have got that just love
we've always we've always like had the
idea of they should have done this but I
don't think I've ever heard of anything
of like any rumors or any myths or
anything like that so actually hearing
it from him
was I can't where I where I heard it but
um it was ages ago but but I'd like say
I didn't think it was I didn't think it
was a true story so him to like yeah um
ah then he had this idea and he
basically went look
practically we've got all these sets
we've got the time we can get them you
know let's try to get the money um yeah
we knew that there was the SGA movie and
I knew that there was going to be the
third sg1 movie that was supposedly
going to focus on O'Neal that was the
generally the plot was it Revolution or
was that um oh I'm G toet mixed up now
my brain's just buzzing Extinction was
the Stargate Atlantis movie Revolution
was the one that was going to reveal the
Stargates to the world but this this
third one that was going to be
a a planned like rescue mission was yeah
something I've never I've never heard
heard that two movies that I know of and
it was I rumored I'm going to be looking
into that bit more and thinking about
that more um but those are the two big
things that that that came out of me for
it that was just um oh and it gave us a
few little hints on what his script
would have been an enemy coming in from
another galaxy um I have heard that
rumored before but um it's nice to have
that sort of
confirmed and um that it was going to
you know um I would love to know that
was and then it sounds it sounded to me
like though that we were going to the
other Galaxy and it was a purpose built
gate so whether that then opened the
door for them to come the other way
maybe would have been I don't I don't
know was speculating completely but
that's something I was wondering about
really when he said that because if it's
a purpose built gate to get to this
other Galaxy surely there needs to be
another gate in that Galaxy to connect
to so maybe the Ancients would have went
there at some point we' have learned
probably a little bit more about the
Ancients yeah yeah yeah and maybe they
went there but then like met this this
race and was like no we can't we can't
stay it was going to be a completely new
villain it was going to be somebody that
we' never seen before never um from a
completely different galaxy
um yeah we said it would be evil fings
and it will be damn it um I I just yeah
I just I love that you know they kept
saying that it was going to be 90 89
minutes I was just like it should be
three lots of 38 minutes just just think
down my head um I I love how we said it
was going to be 89 minutes and then we
ended up being on there for two hours it
was the I I kept I did sort of mention
to Tommy I thought the first the 10
minutes bit at the start wasn't long
enough I know we were late starting
because we were struggling a little bit
with the electronics but um the 10
minutes at the start wasn't really long
enough to talk about the things we'd
would love to talked about um you know
we talked about MGM I mean Brad said
there that that they were looking at the
Sci-Fi channel again for the new
Stargates show and that's not what I
heard at all um I heard that Amazon were
the ones that we're trying to buy it so
whether that's
um whether this that Amazon rumor wasn't
true or whether Amazon were coming in
afterwards but I've heard several times
that Amazon before MGM they bought MGM
that's what they were looking at they
going or whether it's going to be one of
those things that it actually which has
done quite a lot that it's sci-fi in
America and internationally Amazon which
that
happens interally we've got a Sci-Fi
channel in this country we but it's like
250 something number 250 something on
the thing and it it doesn't really get
like gets crap shows basically so I
don't know whether that was just going
to be something that MGM were looking at
maybe but so both things might been true
is what I'm trying to say but um but
it's just fascinating to and at the end
of the day I I I ran downstairs and told
my wife Brad right at the end of our
little interview went I love your I love
what you do and you know you guys know
more about what's going on on Amazon
than I do and it's just I was just
like thank you so much for saying that
br um and you know because for a long
time we got we did get called Liars at
times and you know and particularly me I
got attacked for being you know and it's
not nice it's not nice when you know you
you're
doing trying to get information out
there about a CH a show you really love
and you're thinking Gators are going to
love this I me Gator going to lose their
mind about this information I'm being
told and then people just turn around
and go that's [__] making it up it's
like oh come on yeah I a few of those
comments on Reddit because I posted the
the the still you know the image on
there saying this is going to happen
it's going to be live streaming on here
and then there was some a few people on
there basically like who is Sidra like
I'm annoyed that sidra's on there
because they're just liars and I put
them in their place basically I was like
we're
not doesn't think we are
so Brad right likes us yeah Brad likes
stuff he watched my he watches that
stuff and he you know he I've got a
tweet scheduled for half past nine
thanking him in the hopes that he'll
follow
me good let's hope so I'll I'll send him
you link um at the end of I mean I just
think anybody that says that we're a
bunch of like that I mean Jenny styen
blew that out the water a year ago
anyway when she basically came on and
gate world have repeated 90% of the the
stuff we've come out with um deadline
then came out thing is I I understand
why people think it I understand why
people get disillusioned and don't like
what comes out of this channel I get it
because we say things because they're
true at the time yeah and we're like we
we speculate on dates and things like
that and we go hopefully we'll get it by
this and then it doesn't happen but it's
not like it's frustrating it's
frustrating for us like I I get that
it's frustrating for everyone else as
well but it's not our fault
like well I mean gate world did a story
in the week saying that it's probably
going to be well or they thought they
didn't say it would be announced at New
York ComiCon but they said this might be
this could be announced at New York
ComiCon and Amazon have got the think
and then saying so be to call them a
bunch of Lies if it doesn't happen and
that's all we've ever done it's just
like this could happen or or or you know
there were there are discussions that
this could happen and a lot of the time
always said oh you like I no because I
never said it was going to happen in the
video I talked about something that was
disgusted that's not the same um and but
then this stuff does come out you know
and it does get and people like Jenny
styen come out and say yeah that was
true when we said Bad Robot had pitched
I got called all sorts and then a couple
of months later Jenny fin come yeah they
did [__] um and you know and and I I
loved that when she did that thing on
gate she went I don't know how they
found that out but I'm like I know how I
find
out um but um I can't say but I know how
you know it's
um
yeah so yeah it for me it's just
like thank you for Brad for doing that
because he didn't have to he didn't have
to say that you know and it's um it's
it's it's really nice to to hear that
and then you know we get people like
Jenny Sten who we're hopefully going to
have on the channel in a couple of weeks
we've been trying to get on for a while
she's worried she might actually hurt
our Channel and I say I don't care just
just get on come on um she she can't
hire her Channel I mean
I don't I don't understand why why why
she thinks she's going to hurt the
channel she doesn't think there there
are people at MGM that
maybe I don't care about them neither do
I I all I care about you might disagree
you probably won't it's just to get
people on who can talk about
Stargate I want to get people on that
have the the attitude of of loving the
Stargate franchise as much as we do and
then I want those people on I mean and
Jenny has more energy than the than a
black hole she just has um black hole is
a bad example because that makes it
sound like she's like more energy than
the sun I should have just gone with
that but actually black holes have more
energy than the Sun but you know what I
mean um I was been a bit literally but
yeah she has just more energy in the Sun
and like said when we when she wherever
on me and you won't get a wood in
edgeways God love her I know we
won't this off but it'll be fantastic
and it'll be super insightful because
everything she talks about yeah is
interesting a NE time to do with
Stargate fair enough but it's still
interesting oh she's oh she's she's
amazing she's one of my favorite people
I just I love talking to her and every
time you know I I'll I'll message you
with with something that's I'm hearing
and you know the amount of times she
comes back and says I'm hearing the same
thing but you can't share it I'm like a
just you're killing me um but um you
know it's just
like I just yeah I [__] love this
Channel and and and I love you guys in
the community and I love that you know
I've made friends with Matt and stormy
and Harris and Melvin and Mike and all
these other people that have appeared on
the channel over the over the year you
know and it's just like just great yeah
more energy than a zpm that's really
what I should have said U that's there
you go wish I thought that but guys I'm
just really hope you guys enjoyed it
throw us a thumbs up if um you enjoyed
it in the in the comments because that
would be amazing and um read what David
B said we all agree what did David B say
I missed
it um this isn't a postmortem LS cheer
up we believe you you must be coming
down the Brad effect I'm just buzzing um
honestly I'm just buzzing and it's yeah
it's just it's just nice to like when
the brand said that basically because
like I said it didn't have didn't have
to and we I think we got a lot of
insights into things that we um
weren't expecting and I was oh you no
know Brad was dying to say and just knew
he couldn't um about some of the plots
that he he had in mind what a book that
will be though in a few
years you know these are the these are
you know out of the out of Brad's mind
these are the things I wanted to do
these are the things I would have done
if I have got half a
chance how how much would we all when
I'll read that
I'd read it yeah
100% absolutely loved it I'd read it and
review it and do the audio book ended
the audio
book we do do a forward can I do a
forward me shut up
Brad well we're obviously gonna analyze
a bit of that over the next week or so
we'll there'll be stuff going on um
sidre .co.uk we'll write up a few bits
and we'll try and you know read between
the lines a few of the bits that were
said we will be getting some videos up
very quickly of little edits from that
because you know it's two hours
um yeah Brad right if I did it that's
what we want yeah that's that should be
his Memoir you know or at least a
chapter
um yeah it's it's sci-fi question um we
will be live tomorrow I don't know to be
honest I don't know I'm a little burned
out from this weekend I have to admit in
the last few days trying to build up
towards this it's just been it's just
been nuts and um I hope getting some
like doing some overtime to pay for all
these super chats car great job first
timers with a legend Brad time
yeah honestly tell the people how
nervous have you been all
day incredibly I messaged Jay this
morning I was
like I was like I'm super nervous and he
was like yeah well you said you're not
and then what was it like 2:00 you went
okay now I'm nervous just clicked in I
thought H we're having we're two hours
away I was met talking to Chris um
Christina from three fry short on Tik
Tok last night and she was like how do
you feel about it and I went honestly
I'm I'm completely like bricking it
like because it's it's the anticipation
of what if I say something that's like
going to offend him or what if I'm going
to
what what if I say the wrong thing what
if I just make myself to like a [__] in
front of like nearly a thousand people
like yeah what if Brad wght turns around
and says that's a stupid question you're
an
idiot what if Brad turns around to me
and says shut up Matt like that's gonna
break my even break my heart break my
heart
man
um but it was just no yeah yeah we were
up first we were up first as we were
first because because we we were the
reason it bloody happened because we
kind
of I'm sure then it was the companion is
reason why it happened but us bugging
Brad for the last couple of months going
please come a sidet trck please come a
sid trck please come um uh was was was
did help yeah um and uh yeah it was just
great
and Brad told just stood up mate happy
birthday Christmas and for the next
couple years you're welcome
I'm gonna you told me to shut up I'm
gonna clip it I'm gonna stick it in here
you know in the um in the brand section
of of of streamyard and it's just going
to be sitting there as a video clip and
whenever you want whenever you want you
can click that
button that is perfect actually do that
right guys um I have to call it even
honestly I got TK Batman's already got
the clip he's already done it it's on
the Discord apparently it's on Discord
ah brilliant so um just guys just thank
you so much thank you for the comments
you've been dumping on us all week so
that you really inspired all of our
questions we got to two questions we
didn't get to ask um I'm sorry about
that um I think other people did kind of
touch on our questions so only what was
integral to are you have you found it
are you
happy okay
um I don't
downlo there you go I'm going to have to
watch that in a second send me the link
um yeah I think the people we were
asking what was sort of core to the
principles of Stargate that he need to
bring through but I think other couple
of people asked questions that sort of
touched on that so um it was great and
just I loved
it I did as well thank you for doing
that with us Matt
because well thank you thank thank
everyone thank the companion thank
everyone for watching thanks Brad yeah
and the companion and dial the gate who
are absolute sweethearts and um gate
world are absolute sweethearts they were
so kind um sorry uh Darren I always get
Darren and David mixed up David at the
end no Darren who's gate World Darren D
Darren is gate well David is Dar gate
keep mixing them up um Darren as say was
it everything you hoped for and I'm just
like
yeah I freaking love that and then n
came
on I know I said I put in the um in the
in the comments does this count as Rick
being on our Channel I think so yeah
Rick yeah Richard nson has been on our
Channel being just brilliant Richard
Dean Anderson with his genius humor and
just even then just being really
sarcastic and I loved it at the end he
went congratulations on whatever this
is wa is he lost God man he's lost a lot
of weight I know um yeah it was just it
was just lovely lovely right I'm going
to call it in evening because I say I'm
I don't know about you but I'm exhausted
this has been bouncing my head week and
I'm absolutely exhausted and my throat
is going so um and I think I might have
coid everyone's two or three people have
got coid that really close to me and
I've started feeling sick so I'm like
for the love of God I don't want Co so
um but my nose is couldn't be here today
Brad because he has coid oh could you
imagine
Brad Brad no i' i' have done I just wor
a
mask you can't transmit
it just in case just in case um no uh
it's just amazing thank you so much guys
right well let's call it an evening and
um I'm going to go and cuddle my wife
guys thank you so much I don't know if
we're going to be live tomorrow or not
we'll see um I see how the day goes um
but if we're not we will see you next
week
but
indeed indeed that's a way to end indeed
goodbye everybody see you later